early ruiz es un profesor de sociología
venezolano pero a pesar de tener una
formación superior y de ser un
trabajador público su salario no les
sirve para vivir algo que le ha obligado
a ser también repartidor y dependiente
en una tienda de vinos pluriempleos con
los que en total apenas alcanza 400
dólares mensuales una situación que
denuncia lo que debería ganar
1400 dólares se hacer a lo que era el
mundo un profesor persona como una
gigante antes prerrevolucionario un
profesor con 1400 dólares no tenía que
tener estos trabajos mahler o se podía
dedicar plenamente a la investigación
actualmente mi sueldo son 90 dólares
entonces si ciertamente yo no tengo
digamos la alternativa pero el caso de
early ruiz no es algo aislado los
maestros han sido uno de los colectivos
más afectados por la crisis que sacude
al país desde hace años una situación
que ha hecho que miles de ellos salgan a
las calles durante estas semanas para
denunciar sus malas condiciones y
reclamar el pago íntegro del bono
vacacional un extra que oscila entre los
100 y 200 dólares que el gobierno de
nicolás maduro todavía no ha pagado pero
recuerde eso que él viene desde muy
abajo entiende y quien no tiene aquí
ahorita donde está es somos nosotros el
pueblo que lo tienen aquí donde está
ahorita entonces que que se aboque y que
cumpla con lo que tiene que cumplir como
presidente tras las protestas el
ejecutivo prometió que esta semana se
pagará íntegramente la cantidad aunque
hasta el momento eso no ha sucedido la
pobreza ha hecho que desde 2017 más del
50 por ciento de los 370 mil profesores
que tenía venezuela salieran del país